you can't pause a movie on the big
screen but don't you wish you could
sometimes to get a better look at
batman's first big moment or to see all
the details in the riddler's hideout
keep watching for more pause-worthy the
batman moments
the opening sequence to the batman will
easily be one of the most talked about
scenes just because of the foreboding
tone it sets it's akin to the swelling
dread one feels as michael myers stalks
his prey in a halloween movie viewers
begin the film gazing through the eyes
of an enigmatic killer as he spies on
his victim the victim here is gotham's
mayor who sits unsuspecting in the
privacy of his luxurious abode as the
mayor views the public reaction to his
own campaign being broadcast on
television he's entirely unaware of the
danger that lurks in the shadows
hauntingly the figure of the riddler is
seen lying in weight not even five feet
away from his intended victim paul
dano's acting skill is on full display
here he can make your skin crawl with
just the movement of his eyes there's a
lot to savor in this sequence
particularly for viewers who have an
appreciation for horror themes and a
creepy atmosphere
the arrival of a film's title character
is often cause for a grand entrance
especially for a character as popular as
batman after the film moves on from its
horrifying introduction of the riddler
robert pattinson's bruce wayne speaks to
the audience via a sullen voiceover that
underscores the bleak and depressing
outlook of a city riddled with crime
while he's unsure whether he's actually
doing any good there is one thing he is
certain of criminals feel uneasy when
the bat signal shines in the sky and for
good reason
when that light hits the sky
[Music]
it's not just a call
it's a warning on a subway a gang that
looks to be inspired by the joker based
on their face paint targets an unlucky
soul and begins assaulting the poor man
quickly the sounds of footsteps can be
heard from within the dark tunnel
opposite the attackers the gang stops
and looks on waiting to see what emerges
from the dark as batman steps out into
the light he provides a demonstration of
his fear-inducing tactics by brutalizing
the gang's apparent leader in front of
them some stay and fight while others
flee it's a visceral display of batman's
rage and the scene earns its place as a
crowd-pleasing starting point for
batman's journey
long before the batman arrived in
theaters audiences knew for quite some
time that the penguin was going to have
a role in the film given that the story
takes place early in batman's
crime-fighting career the penguin isn't
quite yet the crime lord comics readers
know him to be he operates the iceberg
lounge under the mobbed-backed
supervision of carmine falcone colin
farrell absolutely disappears into the
penguin beneath prosthetics and makeup
work despite his altered appearance he
manages to nail the mannerisms of an ego
maniacal crook vying for power all the
fun begins when the dark knight heads to
the iceberg and questions the penguin
regarding his possible associations with
the recently deceased mayor seeing the
penguin and knowing that colin farrell
is buried beneath that grungy exterior
and slimy attitude is quite impressive
viewers might find themselves scanning
the character for any identifiable
aspect of the feral they remember but
they'll be hard-pressed to find anything
despite his own penchant for crime and
corruption the penguin positions himself
as one of the film's more interesting
characters even though he has little to
do with the burgeoning threat of the
riddler
throughout the film the riddler taunts
the residents of gotham with each kill
of course he believes that he's doing
the city a service by rooting out
corruption he also wants to get batman's
attention hoping that the vigilante will
side with him and his crusade to punish
the wicked i think i'm his last target
the news regularly shows recorded
threats that the riddler has posted in
an effort to gain clout and attention
throughout his campaign when the police
finally detain the riddler they
investigate his apartment which is
littered with newspaper clippings and
details of gotham's past and present the
riddler's cluttered abode contains
secrets and details that many fans will
certainly want to pause and scour for
clues to a larger world beyond gotham
city when the riddler discusses the
affluent wayne and arkham families
eagle-eyed fans can see a clipping
referencing edward elliott another
famous gotham city aristocrat those who
remember the elliott family from the
batman comics will recognize this as an
odd to tommy elliot bruce's former
childhood friend who grows up to become
the villainous hush
a batman movie just wouldn't be an epic
dark knight tale without a thrilling
batmobile sequence the batman doesn't
disappoint batman unveils his monster
machine with a thunderous rumble as the
dark knight pursues the penguin in an
effort to learn whether he's an
informant in a case the riddler keeps
referencing he has to deal with
dangerous criminals collateral damage
the penguin enters the freeway driving
the wrong direction dodging cars and
causing massive pileups at one point the
penguin causes a collision that includes
a truck carrying liquid fuel looking in
his rear view mirror he believes the
batman was either forced to stop his
pursuit or taken out in the explosion of
the truck's trailer he hollers for joy
i got you but his excitement is
short-lived as the batmobile comes
careening out of the flames much to the
penguin's horror hot rod enthusiasts who
love cards with some serious muscle and
fans of the batmobile will definitely
want to admire the stunt work and
thrilling visuals on display during this
harrowing sequence
the relationship between batman and
catwoman has long been one of the most
entertainingly complex in comics
although it is yet to be fully explored
on the big screen audiences have had
several opportunities to see the bat and
the cat in action michelle pfeiffer's
take on the role in 1992's batman
returns is unforgettable and anne
hathaway put her own spin on the
character when selena kyle fought side
by side with the caped crusader in the
dark knight rises the batman however
gives us what might be the most comics
accurate portrayal of catwoman yet with
zoe kravitz donning the leather bodysuit
and cat burglar mask when batman follows
selena to find out how she's involved in
the case at hand he discovers her
breaking into a safe commenting on her
uncanny ability to crack them so easily
startled she turns around and starts
fighting him the sequence fits neatly
into the narrative while doubling his
thrilling fan service for everyone in
the audience who's been looking forward
to seeing these characters come together
on screen again if viewers look closely
they can even see that selena is
sporting some wickedly long fingernails
primed for cat-like scratch attacks
thankfully the clash is brief just as
they have so many times before batman
and catwoman quickly form an alliance as
many viewers will no doubt suspect the
riddler's capture isn't the end but it
does set up his end game despite his
arrest he has power in the form of a
group of radical followers he's amassed
they detonate bombs he's planted on
gotham's reservoir walls causing a
devastating amount of water to pour into
the city when batman finally comes to
realize the riddler's terrible plot
fiery explosions can be seen erupting
throughout the city as seen reminiscent
of bane's assault on gotham in the dark
knight rises the results are horrifying
as residents of gotham clamor to reach
higher ground and water sweeps through
the streets the moment adds some serious
tension when audiences sit back and
realize that the riddler may have won
it's not often that the bad guy walks
away as the victor but this villain
managed to bring widespread destruction
to gotham the film's resolution settles
on batman understanding that he has to
do whatever he can to help gotham's
innocence in the face of unrepentant
evil
with the riddler locked up tight at
arkham he can no longer do any harm
directly but he's covered himself by
rallying extremists to his cause through
his online presence with gotham city
flooding and descending into mass panic
and chaos the group seeks to assassinate
a mayoral candidate and kill as many
people as they can at a political rally
the group positions themselves high up
on a rafter where they rain down a hail
of bullets upon the innocence below
batman once again makes a grand entrance
by demolishing the top of the building
with explosives and dropping onto the
rafter before engaging the riddler's
disciples the dark knight pummels and
defeats bad guy after bad guy in a
thrilling combat sequence still early in
his career batman isn't quite the near
perfect crime fighter we know he'll one
day become after recruiting years of
experience on the job he's attacked from
a blind spot and nearly falls off the
rafters surveying his surroundings he
employs the use of smoke to distract his
enemies while he takes each down one by
one
the batman establishes batman and
catwoman's relationship well both have
aided each other and even saved each
other's lives their paths are
interconnected and selena senses that
when she kisses the dark knight she
pleads with him to skip town with her
before realizing he's too fixated on
helping build a better gotham city while
she doesn't believe the city will ever
change that man has hope as the two set
off on their own paths they speed away
on their respective motorcycles despite
the scene coming at the tail end of the
film it's the first moment viewers can
admire the bat cycle in all of its
simplicity and beauty while bleak themes
of corruption and darkness pervade the
batman seeing the caped crusader and
catwoman racing down the road together
side by side offers a glimmer of hope
and optimism for the future even though
they ultimately go their separate ways
it's hard to believe selena kyle is out
of batman's life for good after all
they've been through together
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Music]